olá a todos sua aqui quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais de um
vídeo e o estrago cheguei faz night at
freddy's quatro cursos buscar a segunda
noite eu sei que outras um pouco menos
vídeos mas está complicado pancrácio de
gravar faculdades e fredes porque o jogo
não sei porque não sei dos programas de
gravação mas pronto eu acho que desta
vez vai correr tudo bem eu já tive que
mexer em algumas configurações mesmo
para lá então só à noite 24
ok estamos na noite do estado como eu
diz pessoal já tinha tentado passar esta
noite umas cinco ou seis vezes
os vídeos que alguém os vídeos ficarão
do divulgados por isso não gostei nada
desta noite dois mas espero que desta
vez coisa vai não é eu também já tive
que treinar um pouco e tem tudo a ver
com o som eu tenho que estar muito
atento aos grupos de deus é muito
difícil o pessoal da série a mesmo muito
difícil prestar atenção enquanto estamos
a documentar um vídeo tua vida numa
inspiração eu não sei porque conseguimos
mas e houve inspiração calma ai que era
muito melhor que a espera ainda para
quem já teve do ônibus pois já vi três
mães da cana a passo
a mãe foi abordada ataque e ouviu que
estavam na cama tamanho na cama e não
sei porquê mas nunca me parece nada
dentro do armário
o sabor de ouvir que alguém faça tudo ó
que são duas da manhã
eu não sei se o nosso embora não estava
aqui alguém eu não sei afirmou agora eu
tenho me dedicado à política interna a
danone quer mas saiba disso falhou outra
vez uma faixa na porta
não sei mais nada aqui eu estou um pouco
paraíba
eu vou ser um luxo a romã que engloba
está muito intenso são duas da manhã
ainda têm muito medo de acender a luz só
mas fock negócio aqui uma maleta livro
caim livro o armário e tudo bem está
tudo tranqüilo
a banda larga eu nunca consegui passar
esta segunda noite sem ganhadores na
quina harmonia na cama né
a nona da cana filho da mãe nesta prova
agora mas já foi embora espere que
alguém entrou dentro do meu armário onde
é idolatrado na hora mas eu eu ironizou
força dentro da mochila
aí o fred no fred não fosse assim o
assentado foxy e do meu fosse preciso
para cá não está a ficar muito intenso
tanto bicho em cima da cama como é que
eu consegui descansar assim é preciso
ver o horário preciso um armário
o meu deus como deus o meu deus ai
demônio
o fosso ficou grande camada que
concentra concentra quase conseguiram
quatro da manhã quatro da manhã calma
o primeiro pessoal também acho que ela
foi embora sem ver outra porta rápido
rápido
a festa foi bonita tribunais preciso
arrumar outra vez o foco está havendo
aqui ok está tranqüilo
o que precisa ficar claro é só o bicho
do santo anastácio
o festebom em outra vez mas para quem
gosta de carro nada só demônio daqui ou
maurício mário eu acho que o foco agora
é confiar que a porta direita
houve alguém que deu instruções à porta
rápido rápido mas estamos cá porque as
duas estão a pescar porque a demora em
cima da cama
sai eu não consigo não conseguir pagar
esta [ __ ]
o boneco é outra vez só mas negou que
alguém um pouco para o pessoal para
comer
chic
o fox e faz a porta o maior trunfo que
também é sócio da manhã
nunca tentei assim da manhã esta noite
eu vou conseguir passar este papa
espero que este vídeo tenha ficado bem a
sério eu nunca passei a segunda noite os
vídeos ficarão todos uma bosta eu espero
que desta vez tenha ficado bem gravado
eu espero o que faltam três dias até a
partir daí vamos ganhar isso me liga e
estamos onde estamos na parte já eu
disse pra eu correr mas não conseguiu
arrancar agora sim agora sim jatopé
novato pronta pra esse lado é o próximo
ao freddie gigante tem uma pessoa lá
dentro os embargos não quer conversa com
o fred vai embora já todo suado mil
seria hostil muita pressão tu consegue
encontrar ajudas no passado por elas
antes de ser forte ou cairá então eu sou
forte faço já sabem oque no chão porque
aproxima o fred e ele pois agora tu quer
um balão amanhã é um outro dia
ok fred ganhou o que é isto
isso faz parte do jogo ou não gostou do
que é suposto eu fazer
e eu não sei só tem uma luz para
ascender ao game a chuva não está a
funcionar eu não sei o que tenho que
fazer é que tem que ficar com luz acesa
eu não saí eu vou pagar a luz solar é
melhor pagar a luz escalar eu preciso
descansar ou porque como he ok noite
três pessoal passar os padrões 3g esta
noite 3 vai ficar para o próximo
episódio já sabe quanto eu vou falar em
favorito fica em banho e nós já não joga
no texto mudança
[Música]